a lot of people have been hitting me up
they said we could get shredded we can't
we could do it oh did your butt what
would you oh mark's down what do you see
he's so down what'd he say dude he wants
to help us
he does yeah you tell me i don't know
exactly what he [ __ ] needs to do with
us
ask him say where how do we start is
there a diet plan yeah yeah yeah yeah
some steroids i'm wearing
i'm not i'm not with steroids you're not
in this competition
you're already skinny i'm trying to come
up i'm trying to try to be extra
shredded no i'm trying to come up to you
you and justin should have a competition
put on weight
that's a very complicated thing who
could get fat who could get fat
wait what no yeah they'd be sick bulk up
you know how much funnier you guys would
be if you're fat
i don't think i think people be giggling
at me all the [ __ ] time bro yeah half
my last because my size
come on now come on now come on skip
come on skip i gotta dedicate i gotta
dedicate it to the crowd
but um what does it say yeah he's
totally down to do it
but uh when do we wanna start after i
get back from montana so next week we'll
start so next week we'll start
what we're gonna do is first official
day a month of kicking ass
i would say to january 1st look at you
so it's into a month
you don't think i can get shredded in a
month absolutely not you don't know me
i do know that's kind of i know how the
body works
getting shredded you act like you know
my body this is your body it's a
surprise no
human body you ain't getting shredded a
month homeboy oh [ __ ] you see
jared cannon here do you see him oh you
talking about that professional athlete
on tv
we're a far cry from jared cannon air
dog i was watching the countdown with
him that boy is shred
city big there he is all three faces
oh three come on now come on chappelle
top left
[Laughter]
for real that's real on the left but
then we get him on
him right now that when he's on the
scale what is it what is that
what is it he's got 185
you're talking about real dedication so
if he can do it you can do it brendan
that's what i'm saying
you don't believe in yourself i believe
he puts me in it too yeah exactly huh we
believe in you so much that you try to
pour yeah
i bet you could be like [ __ ] if you
shredded i'd love to hear homeboys
playing
all right all right but you got our back
i know but you got dedicated you got
yeah
he sent us a plan i'm in start next
tuesday okay starting next two days
i had a rice krispie treat on the way
here today when's the last time you had
a rice krispie treat it's been a while
bro i had 16 two weeks ago when i was
home
16 in one sitting like there was like
the coffee i just
yeah can be a dick i just put them down
dog a nice
dark roast with a [ __ ] rice krispie
treat
dark roast
you should have seen chappelle's lips oh
[Applause]
put it down
that's legit joint i told you because
you know she probably likes to smoke a
little i said doug if matt barnes offers
you a joint
you take it hey they're the l.a freaking
weed kings out i know yeah i would not
that see i only do it like it has to be
the last thing i do before i go to sleep
you are like
smoke that not feeling like you don't
need to just fight to me i know because
i feel like you judge me no i don't i
don't give a [ __ ]
you could do math if that's what you
want to do hold on now
i wouldn't recommend doing this before
the pot yeah i was like i got you matt
well
they smoked so much weed back there yeah
wait you're getting high just chilling
watching them podcast yeah
exactly i was getting a little buzz a
little bit i was
i love when they're stu those are my
boys i love those guys yeah
when they're in studio there's good food
they treat me like [ __ ]
when they're here
[Applause]
[Applause]
nature with chen love it he doesn't want
to make it
what's that we're just going to call
this segment how cool is that
how cool is that it should be like
it's actually the national bird of korea
it'll swoop in here there's a trash on
someone's
car truck
or it looks like a truck boom
damn that's kind of hard i didn't know
that i thought
transfers they're like birding
tarantulas but oh
dude get me in here damn that's pretty
dope
don't don't they're fishing their fish
is that dope what's up birds
yeah that wasn't a regular bird though i
mean it's a regular it looks like a
regular like sparrow type
it's a little bit bigger but i don't
know that video birds can see mice from
[ __ ]
all the way up the top yeah but remember
i wanted to get a neck tattoo
this is the burgundy i'm literally
thinking of getting this bird what's
that i'm gonna get
lunch and get out though you'll [ __ ]
that chip
what you don't like it you don't like
this suppose no you're talking about
that hot chip
oh my goodness i thought you said [ __ ]
that joey my bad
that [ __ ] was yeah tell me about that
now talk to me about that who's terrance
who commented on it
terence ross the basketball player oh
did he come to the show
uh no they couldn't find a babysitter oh
yeah he's coming back out here though
ain't none man baby's always good he's
good peoples man that chip was
hot as [ __ ] what did it feel like what
did it feel like
uh cause i saw y'all throwing up and you
drinking milk
i was all i mean don't you around was
hot but like my boy austin was it
depends on how you ate it
the way like i i put him on chewed and
swallowed it fast yeah see you did that
it got stuck in
on me because like you know like when
you're eating like a peanut butter
and like bread or whatever yeah it stays
it's that's what happened to me peanut
butter is thick so it just stayed and it
was like i couldn't get it down
the challenge that although so hard the
tick tock dummies are doing
is uh yeah they do it without drinking
anything yeah yeah like the cinnamon
challenge
no the cinnamon challenge you just you
just try to swallow it
oh anyway it's not no but the cinnamon
challenge is not spicy
you don't clean up this area call them
on chapel oh them damn
that came from your girl right yeah my
mom was like hold on i know she sees
ralph
i know she sees we're out
[Music]
it was [ __ ] hot what's that y'all
going to hades
yeah he's so stupid the devil he makes
me laugh so [ __ ] hard
right like that man is just like so
just just fires up shout out to
louisiana